different
on this Saturday night bracing for a
fresh offensive
the race to find safety as Russia
refocuses its attacks new pledges of
support our Collective response must
keep pace and an urgent appeal to end
the violence they have to be everything
to force Russia to see peace also
tonight infections on the rise these are
uncharted waters for us covid cases
spread again with a warning and even
bigger wave is still to come
leadership on the line and I have not
been a perfect leader I've made mistakes
Jason Kenney fights for his political
life
and music to your ears and eyes the BC
band singing and signing their way to a
more inclusive audience I asked for
directions
[Music]
global national reporting tonight soapy
Louie
good evening and thanks for joining us
Ukrainian President Vladimir zielinski
says his country is ready to take on
Russian forces amassing in the East but
in order to win he needs greater support
from the International Community
they have to do everything to hold
Russian soldiers and their commanders
accountable for their crimes against the
Ukrainian people
sanctions must be imposed the Russian
war crimes machine should be denied its
capacity to act
zielinski's comments came as Western
Nations pledged billions of dollars in
further support for Ukraine during a
fundraising event co-hosted by prime
minister Justin Trudeau but the urgency
is increasing for immediate health on
the ground as Russia escalates its
aggression in the East and ukrainians
frantically Evacuate the region Karen
Lieberman begins our coverage tonight
and a warning some of the images in her
story are disturbing to watch
urgent calls for people in eastern
Ukraine to flee immediately as Russia
ramps up its shelling just a day after a
missile strike on a packed train station
survivors search through the debris
where more than 50 were killed scores
more seriously injured
but there is little time to spare and
even less time to grieve ten
humanitarian corridors have been agreed
upon to evacuate people from besieged
Southern cities
and donors from around the world are
heeding the desperate calls to help the
more than 4 million people who have fled
the war with a combined 9.1 billion
euros my friends as a humanitarian
crisis deepens and needs continue to
grow our Collective response must keep
Pace prime minister Justin Trudeau
co-hosted the stand-up for Ukraine
pledging event and announced an
additional 100 million dollars in
humanitarian support plus a series of
measures to help ukrainians coming to
Canada new income supports for
ukrainians for up to six weeks for those
who need it after they arrive to get
them started here in Canada on the right
foot and ensure that they have access to
the basic necessities we're also going
to provide temporary hotel
accommodations for up to two weeks not
all have fled kombucha Valerie lesenko
returns to see the damage to her
hometown people with their hands tied
people tortured murdered and and this
just breaks my heart you know but I'm
sure
um I'm optimist so I'm sure we'll
rebuild this city they can't do it alone
says Ukraine's president who met with
the British prime minister in Kiev we
will give the you the support that you
need the economic support but also of
course the defensive Military Support
the UK has offered to send 120 armored
vehicles
missile systems just as we are defending
ourselves again the greatest tyranny of
all so the other people of the world
should bravely resist this tyranny
Karen Lieberman Global News
while the invasion of Ukraine was among
the key points in the liberal budget
unveiled Thursday with the renewed
emphasis on defense spending and
military aid for Ukraine on the west
block this weekend Mercedes Stevenson
speaks with Finance Minister Christian
Freeland about Russia's aggression and
Canada's next steps Mercedes
Sophie Deputy Prime Minister Christian
Freeland does not mince her words in
describing the reality of what is
happening in Ukraine as the Russian
Federation targets and murders Ukrainian
civilians
horror
real uh sadness
anger
and determination
I think that it is so important for us
to recognize that what is happening is
an atrocity and it's happening right now
Freeland called Vladimir Putin a war
criminal in her budget speech this week
and this weekend on the west block she
calls for Canadians to Bear witness to
what is happening you know there is
systematic rapes of women in Ukraine are
happening and the accounts I've read
are are just blood chilling in the
budget Freeland designated half a
billion dollars in Military and
financial aid for Ukraine including
money to buy weapons something the
Ukrainian government has been asking for
and that she says Ukraine's Finance
Minister texted her just half an hour
after the budget was announced to thank
her for
on calls for Canada to do more to send a
message to Russia like expelling Russian
diplomats or calling for Russia to be
kicked off the U.N security Council
Freeland would not say if Canada will
consider those options that comes after
prime minister Justin Trudeau indicated
hesitancy about expelling Russian
diplomats from Canadian soil well I
think the most important next step is to
do everything in our power to ensure
that Putin is defeated that is the
single most important security challenge
for Canada and the world there's also an
interesting twist in the federal budget
one that would allow the Canadian
government to use seized Russian assets
in Canada to send money to help Ukraine
rebuild Sophie Mercedes Stevenson in
Ottawa thanks Mercedes and you can catch
the full interview with Deputy Prime
Minister Christia Freeland tomorrow on
the west block right here on global
Pakistan's prime minister Imran Khan has
been ousted in an historic no-confidence
vote following a more than 13-hour
impasse in Parliament opposition parties
were able to secure 174 votes in support
of the motion 172 were needed to pass
Khan now becomes the first Pakistani
prime minister to be ousted by a
no-confidence vote critics blamed him
for mismanaging the country and failing
to revive an economy hit hard by the
pandemic Khan accuses the U.S of
triggering his removal from office but
has provided no evidence to back up that
claim
and ominous warning tonight from
America's Top infectious disease doctor
the U.S is seeing a surge in new
covid-19 cases but it's believed they
will really take off after the summer
Capitol Hill is in the midst of a major
outbreak right now following an unmasked
dinner with some of the country's top
politicians and as Jennifer Johnson
reports China and the UK are also seeing
a dramatic rise in cases
for the first time since January new
cases of covid-19 are rising again
Across America driven by the highly
contagious ba2 sub-variant that Omicron
stealtharian is also spreading overseas
Shanghai has been locked down
Funeral Directors in Hong Kong are
overwhelmed that's probably the worst
situation uh that I've ever seen in this
Pro in my profession in Korea England is
also seeing a dramatic spike in new
cases hospitalizations and deaths are
rising too the top White House kova 19
expert says while cases are increasing
in America the next major wave is still
months away it is likely that we will
see a surge in the fall these are
uncharted waters for us cases are up
almost 60 percent in Washington D.C
affecting some of the nation's most
powerful players house Speaker Nancy
Pelosi attorney general Merrick Garland
and Commerce Secretary Gino raimondo at
least 53 lawmakers staffers and
journalists tested positive after
attending last weekend's annual Gridiron
dinner U.S President Joe Biden did not
attend but has had close contact with
some who now have the virus despite all
the precautions we take and even with
the president it being double boosted he
could still test positive for covid the
White House is urging Americans to get
booster shots an independent study
showed covid-19 vaccines saved 2.3
million lives in the U.S and prevented
17 million hospitalizations but less
than 50 percent of Americans have been
boosted the vaccines are just losing
their effectiveness that's why you're
seeing so many infections even in
vaccinated people but what you're not
seeing is as many deaths and
hospitalizations while many Americans
have grown tired of trying to prevent
copper 19 others are keeping their guard
up I believe that it's not over yet so
uh and continue to wear my mask Dr fauci
says kova 19 is here to stay with more
variants coming and he says vaccines may
become a yearly event similar to getting
an annual flu shot Jennifer Johnson
Global News Washington
well as provinces ditch Health
restrictions across this country there
are new fears about how serious a
potential sixth wave of covid-19 could
get Ontario is already seeing a spike in
hospitalizations and with infections
spreading there are fewer Health Care
staff to treat patients Megan King
reports
well I think everybody in Ontario needs
to know that we're in a very large surge
of the sixth wave of Omicron it's
infectious as coveted cases continue to
climb in Ontario experts like infectious
disease specialist Dr dick zoutman are
calling for a renewed effort in
encouraging vaccination and covid-19
safety protocols the third dose that was
offered starting around December of last
year when the Omicron wave hit turned
out to be a game changer because the
first and second dose were very
important no question but the third dose
added a layer of extra protection
against getting very sick and having to
end up in hospital taking it into the 90
range of protection
according to provincial Cova data 91 of
ontarians 12 plus are fully vaccinated
having received at least two doses this
compares to only 59 of 12 plus ontarians
who have received a third booster dose
I'm one of those people I was really
well the two shots were important the
booster like to me is kind of like get
the chance I'll take it and if I don't
want to go out of my way we're all
boosted I don't know I guess if you have
any side effects and you've had the
first two it makes sense to get the
third because you know the immunity I
guess only lasts so long I'm going to
get the booster I got covered when I was
going to get the booster and I was like
I'll wait a few weeks because I think
there's some science behind that
hospitalization numbers are increasing
and so are Healthcare staff absences as
of April 6th the Scarborough Health
Network reports 189 staff and Physicians
off work Unity Health reports 320 for
its staff the other thing we need to
take into account is our Health Care
system is really stressed right now our
hospitals are struggling because so many
of our staff are off sick and hospitals
throughout Ontario are having a hard
time finding the nurses and the doctors
and all of the skills that to provide
that care for those people who are in
hospital at this time Megan King Global
News Toronto
foreign
Kenny's political future put to the test
coming up his high stakes appeal to
Alberta conservatives and later a 70
million dollar ticket to space the
private astronauts who just made history
Alberta Premier Jason Kenney gave the
speech of his political life today as
voting begins on his leadership
is it any Wonder
is it any wonder that we've had some
internal tensions and frankly some
internal Division I don't I'm not
surprised
but let us learn from the lessons of
History lest we repeat them as I say if
we indulge ourselves
in a cycle of recrimination of internal
art debate of division
I fear that we'll never come back from
it
United conservative party members were
supposed to meet in person but with
fears Kenny would be defeated in a
one-day vote the UCP board decided on a
mail-in contest a party claiming venue
capacity limits would be exceeded that
means results won't be in until next
month and with a provincial election
only a year away the UCP has little time
to get all its infighting sorted out
Heather urich's West has more
Jason Kenney is trying to keep his
political career alive on Thursday Brian
Jean the man who lost to Kenny in the
united conservative party's first
leadership race was sworn back into the
Alberta legislature he won a by-election
last month and his intentions now are
pretty clear we know that we have some
very serious issues the most important
being the NDP in the next election is
going to get an overwhelming majority if
we keep the same leader Brian Jean and
former Alberta opposition leader
Danielle Smith have both declared
they'll run to lead the UCP before Jason
kenney's leadership review has even
taken place they're both raising rural
issues uh they're both raising uh coved
restrictions issues
um so that is clearly the the challenge
that Kenny is looking at but there's a
lot of moderates in the party who have
also been upset with Jason Kennedy's
approach frustration with Kenny could be
why interest in this leadership review
is so high what began as an in-person
AGM with a couple of thousand people
turned into a virtual mail-in ballot
contest after the expected attendance
swelled to more than fifteen thousand
there's been a lot of unhappiness on the
part of the rebels in the party about a
mail-in ballot
um I think because they are concerned
that this is uh much easier to
manipulate the RCMP is still
investigating allegations of voter fraud
related to the last UCP leadership
contest in 2017.
[Applause]
Kenny has spent recent weeks positioning
himself as the moderate choice for
albertans a winner who will lead the UCP
to another mandate the party now facing
big decisions with little time to waste
a provincial election against a popular
and familiar opposition just one year
away Heather urics West Global News
Calgary
just ahead the generation gap in an age
of disinformation who is at highest risk
next
you're watching global national
pandemic uncertainty over covid-19 and
Russia's war in Ukraine have accelerated
the spread of misinformation
disinformation and conspiracy theories
online tonight on the new reality Donna
Friesen looks at what you can do to
protect yourself and your loved ones
Donna
this week we shine a spotlight on the
problem of disinformation and
misinformation it's an issue I care
about as a journalist and as a parent
and there are so many of us who have to
face the toxic swamp of lies and hate
swirling on social media and are
concerned about what it's doing to the
fabric of society to the future of
democracy we got some insight on where
this is all headed and who is most
vulnerable from Jesse Miller he's a
digital democracy Advocate here's part
of our conversation there's a whole
generation growing up as you said that
have like my son who is 17 who know
nothing but the digital age it this is
their era social media is almost like a
second language are you suggesting that
they're not vulnerable then because
they're growing up in this and they're
so much more self-aware the
vulnerability has to run on a spectrum
and so the idea of vulnerability when we
talk to kids about Internet safety has
always been about protect yourself from
predication currently in Canada we see a
large amount of seniors people who are
in let's say the 55 plus demographic of
financial viability being targeted who
are falling prey to scams online where
it's you know buy gift cards online or
somebody who's targeted you for a CRA
scam and we have a lot of young people
who don't fall for that kind of
catfishing mentality because they've
understood what it means to fall for
something in a gaming environment so
they're digital literacies their media
literacies are more Adept to kind of
sussing out the garbage and the same
applies to their idea of collecting
information and kind of going through
misinformation we also take you inside
the David and Goliath fight against big
Tech it's an uphill battle Facebook and
Google spent about 120 million dollars
lobbying the U.S Congress last year more
than big oil or tobacco but Imran Ahmed
is undaunted his colleague Joe Cox was
the British MP who was murdered in 2016
by a man who was radicalized online now
Imran is making it his life's work to
push social media platforms to recognize
they have a duty of care and to see to
it that they're held accountable for the
malignancy they monetize online
all right Donna thanks for that you can
watch all of that tonight on the new
reality right here on global
[Music]
message even for those who can't hear it
Dragon SpaceX on a big loop
an historic Landing today as the first
all-private team of astronauts arrived
at the International Space Station crew
members were met by the Seven astronauts
already on board Montreal entrepreneur
Mark pathy is part of the private team
who each paid nearly 70 million dollars
for the trip they will spend eight days
on the station conducting a series of
science experiments before heading back
home to Earth
well the movie Coda has put a spotlight
on the deaf community and their families
but even before the film won best
picture at the Oscars a BC band was
hitting the stage proving music is
indeed a universal language whether you
can hear it or not they're called half
asian with Amy the coda because that's
exactly what they are Jay Durant reports
they formed a new band they just needed
a good name and Amy Braun and Ian
Griffis wanted to make sure they got it
right we got a book from the library
called I think naming your business no
the book was called hi my name is
awesome
[Music]
instead they decided to keep it personal
the name is half asian with Amy the coda
a salute to their families and their
experiences growing up I'm a coda and a
coda stands for a child of a deaf adult
so my mother is deaf my father is
hearing
[Music]
inspiration for more inclusive shows Amy
dances and signs the lyrics their
performances are giving people who are
deaf or hard of hearing a reason to go
see live music thank you Amy and I am
from fantastic one deaf woman came up
after a gig and explained how for the
first time ever she actually had a song
stuck in her head
[Music]
because she had full access to the
lyrics She had never had that before she
had gone to lots of music events she
loves music but she had never known what
the words were if I were a bird though
they've worked on other music projects
separately in the past just before the
pandemic the couple decided to make
music together music put a positive
message some of it motivated by racist
experiences yeah I've just been walking
on the street someone has looked at me
and said something races to my face and
it's like whoa I asked for directions
they're booked to play eight festivals
in the coming months hoping Their
audience will keep growing I have a
vision for a huge stage and you know a
formation of deaf dancers
to bring more people into the fold
um I think would be a really beautiful
thing
Jay Durant Global News
and that is global national for this
Saturday night I'm Sophie Louie tonight
your Canada is Peggy's Cove Nova Scotia
we would love to see your corner of the
country so please keep sending your
photos to viewers at globalnational.com
thanks for watching and I'll be back
here tomorrow have a great night
[Music]